wie viele geräte in deinem haushalt
haben eine batterie smartphones laptops
tablets kameras digitale und analoge
ohren kaum etwas funktioniert heutzutage
ohne die kleinen stromspeicher nicht
einmal ein normales benzin auto könnte
ohne 12 volt blei akku den motor starten
2009 10 werden ungefähr 1,4 milliarden
neue smartphones hergestellt alleine der
bedarf nach lithium ionen akkus für all
diese neuen smartphones hat einen 20
milliarden euro großen markt erschaffen
und das ist erst der anfang während die
mittelschicht in riesigen ländern wie
china und indien immer wohlhabender wird
explodiert auch die nachfrage nach
stromhungrigen gadgets erneuerbare
energien werden zunehmend mit großen
stromspeicher anlagen kombiniert um die
energie dann nutzen zu können wenn wir
sie brauchen und die revolution der
autoindustrie hin zu elektromobilität
fängt gerade erst an
so richtig fahrt aufzunehmen um all das
bewerkstelligen zu können brauchen wir
sichere leistungsstarke günstige und
langlebige akkus also wie sieht die
batterie der zukunft aus
viele von euch schreiben mir dass ich
häufiger videos machen soll als
allererstes mal danke schön ich nehme es
als kompliment und ihr habt vollkommen
recht ich arbeite dran hier auf dem
kanal häufiger was zu machen aber ich
bin eigentlich relativ aktiv nun nicht
immer auf diesen kanal hier
watson ist eine serie von und mit mir im
typischen doktor watson stil und die
themen reichen von block chain und
künstliche intelligenz zu elektroautos
und unserem leben in der zukunft
und das beste es gibt alle zwei wochen
ein neues video von mir mehr dazu
erzähle ich euch am ende des videos aber
wenn ihr jetzt schon interesse daran
habt dann findet ihr einen link zu
what's on unten in der video
beschreibung die ersten primitiven
batterien gab es bereits im jahre 250
vor christus im bereich genutzt wurden
die krüge mit essig kupfer und eisen
wahrscheinlich um silber zu
galvanisieren die erste moderne batterie
wurde allerdings erst 1800 vom
italienischen physiker alessandro volta
erfunden die voltage säule bestand aus
zink kupfer und einem in elektrolyte
punktes stück leder dass die beiden
elemente voneinander trennte
diese reihenfolge wurde dann immer
wieder abwechselnd übereinander
gestapelt um eine höhere spannung zu
erreichen und daher stammt auch der name
voltage säule nur drei jahre später
baute ein deutscher physiker johann
wilhelm ritter dem ersten akkumulator
also die erste formen einer batterie die
man wieder aufladen konnte
50 jahre danach wurde der erste blei
akkumulatoren finden und diese form
kennen wir heute alle aus unseren autos
denn sie ist verantwortlich dafür den
motor zu starten und sie wird zum
problem wenn man über nacht das
standlicht eingelassen hat um die wende
zum zwanzigsten jahrhundert gab es diese
batterie sogar schon in autos damals
allerdings um das ganze auto zu
betreiben ja genau
tesla hat das elektroauto nicht erfunden
batteriebetriebene autos gab schon vor
über 100 jahren und stellten damals eine
echte konkurrenz für verbrenner da um
die jahrhundertwende wurde auch der
nickel cadmium akku erfunden der sich
bis in die 1990 er jahre
für viele geräte etabliert hat 1982
wurde allerdings schon der nickel
metallhydrid akku zur marktreife
gebracht
dieser hatte eine höhere energiedichte
als der vorgänger und verwendete zudem
nicht dass giftige cadmium
als resultat verschwanden die nickel
cadmium akkus nach und nach und heute
sind sie in der eu sogar für die meisten
consumer anwendungen verboten
und dann hat sich noch einmal alles
geändert 1991 kam der lithium-ionen-akku
auf den markt den wir heute alle kennen
und täglich nutzen
basierend auf grundlagenforschung der tu
münchen aus den 70er jahren hatte die
technologie das potenzial die
energiedichte der bisherigen akkus
ungefähr zu verdoppeln
und dieser verdopplung ist es zu
verdanken dass wir smartphones smart
watchers und elektroautos in der
heutigen form überhaupt haben können
denn ohne die hohe energiedichte der
akkus während smartphones viel dicker
laptop akkus nach einem halben tag leer
und smart watch oder e autos praktisch
unmöglich
aber wie funktioniert eigentlich ein
lithium ionen akku an dieser stelle ein
kurzer ausflug in den grundkurs chemie
der siebten klasse
eine batterie besteht aus einer anode
einer kathode und einem elektrolyt bei
einem lithium ionen akku besteht die
kathode auf das einer mischung aus
lithium sauerstoff und einem metall wie
zum beispiel kobalt diese konkrete
mischung nennt man lithium kobalt oxid
und wurde in elektroautos wie dem tesla
roadster oder dem e smart verwendet die
anode besteht meistens aus graphit und
der elektrolyt ist ein leitsatz in einem
lösungsmittel gut diese batterie jetzt
in ein smartphone gesteckt und verwendet
um zum beispiel den bildschirm mit strom
zu versorgen dann bewegen sich
elektronen von graphit über den
bildschirm auf die andere seite der
batterie fließender strom ist nämlich
nichts anderes als sich bewegende
elektronen durch die fehlenden
elektronen entsteht nun aber eine
positive ladung im graphit diese wird
dadurch kompensiert dass positive
lithium ionen durch das elektrolyt zum
lithium kobalt oxid wandern
sobald keine elektronen mehr in der
anode sind ist die batterie leer und
muss wieder aufgeladen werden
hierzu wird dieser ganze prozess und
übrigens auch die bezeichnung von anode
und kathode umgekehrt elektronen fließen
von der jetzt anode in die jetzt kathode
und positiv geladene lithium ionen
wandern durch das elektrolyt um die
ladung auszugleichen
dieser prozess kostet energie aber dafür
erhalten wir potentielle energie in
chemischer form und diese potentielle
energie will freigesetzt werden was
passiert wenn akkus ihre hohe
energiedichte nicht in den griff kriegen
haben wir 2016 gesehen
es entwickelt sich rauch feuer teilweise
explodieren die handys sogar richtig das
ist einer der schwachpunkte von
lithium-ionen-batterien
sie sind nur sicher wenn man sich exakt
an die vorgaben des herstellers hält
elektroauto hersteller müssen ihre
batterien deswegen gut schützen wird das
akkupack beschädigt kann schnell eine
menge hitze entstehen die wiederum die
zellen um sich herum beschädigt eine
kettenreaktion kurzer disclaimer an
dieser stelle
das passiert nur in extrem seltenen
fällen bisherige daten zeigen dass
elektroautos in crashtests sicherer sind
als verbrenner autos das liegt zum einen
an zusätzlichen knautschzonen vorne im
auto da hier kein großer
verbrennungsmotor untergebracht ist und
zum anderen gibt das akkupack dem auto
stabilität
für den fall dass doch ein feuer
entsteht sind die meisten elektroautos
mit einer feuerwand ausgestattet die den
innenraum vom akku pack trend aber
sicherheitsmaßnahmen wie batterie hüllen
und feuerwände kosten geld und sorgen
für zusätzliches gewicht etwas das man
bei elektroautos unter allen umständen
vermeiden möchte um die reichweite zu
verbessern und die vergleichsweise hohe
energiedichte der lithium ionen akkus
naja wenn man sie mit anderen akku typen
vergleicht ist die schön und gut aber im
vergleich mit herkömmlichen benzin wird
sie lächerlich klein
das ist der grund dafür dass e autos
entweder kleine stadtflitzer mit
geringer reichweite sind oder viele
hundert kilo schwere batterien im boden
verstauen müssen
ein weiteres problem ist die
langlebigkeit einer lithium ionen
batterie je nach nutzung können nach 500
ladezyklen nur noch 80 prozent der
ursprünglichen kapazität erreicht werden
ein zyklus bedeutet eine komplett volle
batterie einmal leer machen und wieder
aufladen
bei smartphones passiert das
normalerweise einmal am tag deswegen
halten die akkus in handys auch nicht
besonders lange durch der batterie markt
ist heute schon riesig und wird sehr
bald noch viel viel größer gleichzeitig
lässt unsere heutige technologie so
fortgeschritten sie auch sein mag
und noch viel zu wünschen übrig es ist
also kein wunder dass erfinder
wissenschaftler und konzerne aus aller
welt mit hochdruck an alternativen
forschen
da gibt es zum beispiel lithium schwefel
oder metall luft batterien
es wird auch an kombinationen wie
natrium eisen oder lithium magnesium
geforscht all diese batterietechnologien
haben verschiedene eigenschaften eine
ist besonders energie dicht während die
andere absolut ausdauernd ist und viele
tausend ladezyklen durchhalten kann man
muss immer zwischen energiedichte
maximaler spannung und langlebigkeit
abwägen und setzt man die perfekte
batterie gefunden hat muss sie noch
günstig herzustellen seien
sicherheitsstandards erfüllen und sowohl
bei -20 als auch bei plus 60 grad
celsius funktionieren
deswegen hört man regelmäßig von
durchbrüchen in der batterieforschung in
den medien
es gibt sehr viele verschiedene
möglichkeiten eine batterie zu bauen und
viele dieser optionen lassen sich
vielleicht wirklich schneller aufladen
und haben eine viel höhere energiedichte
als lithium ionen akkus aber wirklich
alle parameter einer guten batterie zu
erfüllen ist extrem schwierig und dauert
lange
viele batteriesysteme für bestimmte
anwendungen werden in den nächsten
jahren nicht marktfähig zu ersetzen
seien eine alternative an der gerade
viele forschen ist die festkörper
batterie
diese soll wie der name schon sagt
komplett aus festem material bestehen
dadurch sollen die batterien
widerstandsfähiger werden sie könnten
wesentlich mehr ladezyklen aushalten
schnelle auf- und entladen werden ohne
dabei schaden zu nehmen und hätten nicht
mehr das risiko in flammen aufzugehen
es gibt sogar bereits prototypen und was
man mit denen alles machen kann ist
beeindruckend
die große herausforderung bei festkörper
batterien ist dass sich die lithium
ionen schnell genug durch den festen
elektrolyt bewegen müssen
bei herkömmlichen lithium-ionen-akkus
ist dieser deswegen flüsse aber die
schiere anzahl an unternehmen die
bereits sehr konkret über diese
neuartige technologie spricht lässt
vermuten dass dieses problem behoben
werden kann
bmw vw samsung bosch im mercedes sogar
dass der hersteller von staubsaugern
will in den nächsten jahren eine
festkörper batterie auf den markt
bringen
und dann gibt es da noch john be good
enough er entdeckte bei seinen
forschungen in den 1970 er jahren an der
university of oxford dass sich lithium
kobalt oxid wunderbar als kathode eignet
er wird deswegen manchmal als vater
moderne akkus bezeichnet das macht es
umso interessanter wenn man hört woran
er aktuell arbeitet gut enough hat
nämlich vor kurzem mehrere paper
veröffentlicht in denen er behauptet
eine neuartige batterie technologie
entdeckt zu haben
sie soll zwei bis drei mal mehr energie
speichern können 23 1000 ladezyklen
aushalten und auch in sehr kalten
temperaturen operieren können
und das beste die batterie soll sogar
günstig herzustellen seien benutzt
wurden dabei alkali metalle und glas
seine behauptungen klingen fast zu gut
um wahr zu sein
fast jeder andere forscher würde mit
solch tollkühnen behauptungen kaum
beachtung finden
aber john booth enough als einer der
väter der modernen batterie dem sollte
man zu hören wenn er so etwas behauptet
wie es hier weitergeht bleibt dennoch
abzuwarten denn bis wir in unseren
smartphones laptops und autos neuartige
batterien haben wird es noch ein paar
jahre dauern
fünf bis acht jahre dauert es mindestens
bis eine experimentelle batterie zur
marktreife gebracht werden kann
experten schätzen dass wir die ersten
festkörper batterien in produkten so um
das jahr 2025 sehen werden
bis dahin müssen noch viele experimente
durchgeführt verhältnisse verbessert und
tests bestanden werden
aber wenn es dann so weit ist dann könnt
ihr euer smartphone drei tage am stück
laufen ohne aufgeladen zu werden
dann muss der laptop akku nicht mehr
alle drei bis fünf jahre sondern gar
nicht mehr ausgewechselt werden und dann
kann ein e auto das genau so viel wiegt
wie ein verbrenner 800 kilometer weit
fahren wenn ihr dieses video gerade
interessant verhandelt dann gefallen
euch garantiert auch meine videos bei
watson auf dem kanal der elektro
industrie spreche ich nämlich über alles
was elektrifiziert ist und was unser
leben in der zukunft verändern wird
smart homes drohnen und 5 g
auf dem kanal gibt es ja schon über 30
folgen von und mit mir und alle zwei
wochen kommt eine neue folge dazu also
abonniert den kanal entweder hier auf
dem kleinen i oder der erste link unten
in der video beschreibung vielen dank
fürs zuschauen bleibt neugierig
[Musik]